antenne de 20h le journal de la
rédaction henri sannier
bonsoir et bienvenue sur le plateau du
journal à la une ce soir une image
catastrophe la voix si c'est celle du
centre de lisbonne ravagé par un
gigantesque incendie
plusieurs dizaines d'immeubles xviiie
siècle ont été détruits par les flammes
le chef de l'état monsieur mario suarez
parle de catastrophe nationale
dans quelques instants nous appellerons
nos envoyés spéciaux à lisbonne avant ça
voici comme chaque soir les autres temps
forts de l'actualité en images
au chili le geste du général pinochet le
gouvernement chilien a décidé la levée
de l'état d'urgence l'opposition avoue
son scepticisme et s'interrogent à
genève l'ouverture d'une négociation
historique après 8 en guerre l'iran et
l'irak discutent sous l'égide des
nations unies
perez de cuellar s'attend à des
pourparlers complexe et difficile
polémique autour d'un ouvrage qui sort
aujourd'hui en librairie
les auteurs qui cachent leur identité
présente 300 médicaments tous surpassés
le ministre de la santé porte l'affairé
devant la justice
on reparle du saint suaire de turin pour
la première fois le vatican a demandé à
trois laboratoires d'effectuer les
analyses des images de cauchemar au
portugal je vous le disais à l'instant
il aura fallu près de douze pompiers
pour circonscrire l'incendié qui a
complètement ravagé le centre de la
ville de lisbonne 12 heures au cours
desquelles plusieurs immeubles datant du
xviiie siècle ont été complètement
ravagés
tous les observateurs sont d'accord
c'est la plus grande catastrophe depuis
le séisme de 1755 un séisme qui avait
totalement détruit la capitale
portugaise tout a commencé ce matin dans
un grand magasin du centre ville
dominique verdeilhan
de la fumée visible à plusieurs dizaines
de kilomètres de lisbonne des sirènes de
pompiers qui ont retenti dans les rues
de la capitale des hélicoptères qui
n'ont pas arrêté toute la journée de
survoler lisbonne les façades témoigne
de ce que le quartier de maïs à un des
plus vieux de lisbonne a vécu
aujourd'hui il a fallu près de dix
heures aux centaines de pompiers
dépêchés sur place pour circonscrire
l'incendié
un incendie qui s'est déclaré très tôt
ce matin à quelques pas du centre
commercial de lisbonne dans un grand
magasin le grand del à un quartier
qu'avait été reconstruit au lendemain du
séisme de 1755 qui avait totalement
détruit la capitale portugaise
le bilan de ce soir n'est que de 1 mort
et de quatre blessés mais une infirmière
de la croix rouge nous confiait
l'inquiétude des sauveteurs
car ce soir alors que le quartier est
totalement bouclé on craint que des
immeubles sinistrés
c'est cool ces immeubles maintenant son
conte danger parce que tout est brûlé et
ils vont tomber
certainement c'est pourquoi nous sommes
là en attendant si quelque chose arrive
s'est excusé moi il ya une version
quartier
oui un peu mais il ya des gens là c'est
difficile de s'éloigner les gens debout
la rue mais c'est dangereux et coup là
je
il est grand temps
vous pouvez tomber une bière sur la tête
dans son édition spéciale de cet
après-midi le quotidien as capital titre
rien ne sera plus comme avant et les
portugais ce soir s'interroge pourquoi
les sauveteurs sont ils intervenus plus
d'une heure après qu'un vigile de
l'escalier semble pas juste a juste à
côté du magasin et donner l'alerté
enfin s'agit-il vraiment comme on a dit
de plus en plus ici d'un incendie
criminel la presse portugaise rappelle
que le directeur du magasin le grande
elle a avait été arrêté la semaine
dernière pour escroquerie et évasion
fiscale et tentative d' incendies dans
les entrepôts et ce dans le seul but de
toucher une prime d'assurance
au chili le geste du général pinochet
suscite aujourd'hui réflexions et
interrogations je vous rappelle que le
gouvernement chilien a décidé hier soir
la levée de l'état d'urgence décision
qui était réclamée par l'opposition
depuis plusieurs années déjà sur place
au chili l'ordre régnait en maître
depuis le coup d'état de 1973 les
libertés publiques était toujours
soumise à rude épreuve c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire
bernard benyamin geste du général
pinochet
peut-être début d'une démocratisation du
chili il est encore trop tôt pour le
dire mais c'est la première mesure prise
par le gouvernement pour crédibiliser le
référendum du mois d'octobre prochain
dans moins d'une semaine en effet les
chefs militaires de tout le pays se
réunissent à santiago pour désigner leur
candidat cette consultation
un candidat qui selon toute
vraisemblance sera le général pinochet
or depuis plusieurs semaines les
manifestations se multipliaient à
santiago pour réclamer la levée de ces
mesures d'exception sans quoi ce
référendum n'aurait aucune valeur
depuis hier c'est chose faite mais dans
l'opposition chilienne s'est
paradoxalement l'inquiétude qui prévaut
ce soir avant la prochaine échéance
électorale
le préparer alors on a compris la
prochaine étape bernard cesser le
référendum si c'est oui pas de problème
pour le général pinochet pas de problème
majeur mais si c'est non pas il risque
d'y avoir quand même un certain
flottement
oui c'est une partie très importante
puisque donc les chiliens vont être
invités à se prononcer sur oui ou non
vous voulez vous que le général pinochet
reste au pouvoir jusqu'en 1997
alors ou bien sûr si le oui l'emporté
pas de problème général pinochet
l'actuel chef de l'état continue ses
fonctions jusqu'en 1997 mais si c'est le
nom qui gagne le gouvernement chilien a
décidé a promis d'organiser des
élections présidentielles dès l'année
prochaine c'est à dire que langue claire
cela signifierait le retour de la
démocratie dans ce pays d'amérique
latine
alors bernard comment peut-on
interpréter le geste du général hier
soir écoutez on sait qu'actuellement
l'armée chilienne est divisé en gros en
deux tendances
il y a les durs avec en particulier le
général pinochet et l'armée de terre et
puis il ya aussi les modérés avec disons
l'aviation et la marine
apparemment les modérés ont gagné
apparemment les modérés semble avoir
remporté une victoire dans la mesure où
les durs ont toujours refusé ce type de
mesures dites libérales comme la levée
des états d'exception mais il ne faut
pas aller trop vite derrière soi le
ministre chilien de l'intérieur disait
que si l'ordre public était à nouveau
menacée il rétablirait immédiatement ces
mesures d'exception
et puis il serait bien étonnant je crois
que l'ale dur de l'art paix et dit son
dernier mot
merci bien là en pologne une grande
confusion régnait hier après la montée
au créneau des syndicats officiels les
confrères ont immédiatement titre et
nouveau coup dur pour le pouvoir et
surtout menace de grève générale
pour l'instant il est très difficile de
faire le point dans la mesure où les
équipes de télévision sont indésirables
depuis plus de 48 heures alors seule
certitude les forces de l'ordre sont
intervenues une nouvelle fois contre les
grévistes
dans le sud du pays quant à lech walesa
il multiplie les mises en garde en
affirmant que le recours à la force ne
résoudra pas les problèmes économiques
et politiques du pays
explications de jacques merlino
travail reprend progressivement dans les
mines de haute silésie
après les interventions des forces de
police les mineurs de plusieurs puits
sont redescendus ce matin au fond les
deux points forts du mouvement de grève
reste donc tchèque chine etc danse dans
les célèbres chantiers navals un premier
pas a été fait vers un début de
négociations le président du club
intellectuel catholique joue le rôle de
médiateur entre le pouvoir et les choix
les a mais après la mise en garde hier
des syndicats officiels
on nous confirme de varsovie que la
crise pourrait bien aboutir à la chute
du gouvernement polonais actuelle
indique alice officiel bien gardé de
comprendre directement général
jaruzelski préférant asséner leurs
courses gouvernement le comité central
du parti communiste polonais se réunira
samedi pour examiner la situation et ont
tiré toutes les conséquences et têtes
pourraient tomber à cette occasion est
d'abord celle du premier ministre
monsieur mère elle se savoir si ces
mesures politiques seront de nature à
apaiser la colère des travailleurs
en attendant les étudiants à leur tour
commence à bouger
une manifestation ait lieu cet après
midi à varsovie
mais la police est rapidement intervenue
et a procédé à plusieurs arrestations
l'étranger en bref on vient d'apprendre
que le gouvernement de birmanie avait
ordonné la libération de tous les
opposants au régime arrêté pendant les
grandes manifestations des jours
derniers selon radio rangoon capté à
bangkok plus de 15 cents personnes ont
été libérées
je rappelle qu' hier le président wang
avait annoncé un référendum pour ou
contre le parti unique dans les semaines
qui viennent
au liban des hélicoptères israéliens ont
effectué tout à l'heure un raid contre
des objectifs palestiniens dans la
banlieue sud-est de saïda sept missiles
ont été lancés contre le camp d'aïn
héloué on ignore pour l'instant si ce
raid a fait des victimes
faut noter qu'il y a quelques jours à
quelques kilomètres de là l'aviation
israélienne avait détruit une station de
radio de l'ol paie qui émettait en
direction des territoires occupés de
cisjordanie et de gaza iran irak la
négociation historique s'est ouverte
aujourd'hui à genève après huit ans de
guerre la paix se négocie en suisse sous
les auspices de l'onu à genève pour
antenne 2
le commentaire de notre envoyé spécial
patricia cost des négociations
historiques qui ont commencé par un
léger faux pas bien symbolique de l'état
d'esprit des deux parties le secrétaire
général des nations unies monsieur perez
des coignard arrivé le premier à temps
côté irakien on attend aussi les
iraniens sont en retard
finalement la délégation menée par le
ministre des affaires étrangères iranien
velayati arrive alors tarek aziz
verachia se décide enfin à pénétrer dans
la salle du conseil
cette salle et illustre c'est ici qu'ont
déjà été signés les accords sur
l'indochine sur la corée en avril
dernier sur l'afghanistan
aujourd'hui pour la première fois depuis
huit ans les deux belligérants vont
maintenant se retrouver face à face
pourparlers de paix derrière eux
plus d'un million de morts et deux
peuples qui vont réclamer des comptes
copé irakiens aux parades fort d'un
récent triomphe militaire pourtant la
nouvelle bataille qui s'annonce
diplomatique cette fois va être rude
côté iranien aucune démonstration
une certaine concentration il ne s'agit
pas de perdre ce combat là le régime
islamique ne s'en relèverait pas rien
n'a encore filtré de cette première
rencontre
mais une chose est sûre le dialogue est
engagé et très sérieusement
pour preuve ils durent déjà depuis
plusieurs heures avec une simple pause
de 15 minutes
pas de portes claquées et une atmosphère
de travail
polémique autour d'un livre que voici
qui sort aujourd'hui dans les librairies
en france son titre 300 médicaments pour
se surpasser physiquement et
intellectuellement
a priori la recette a l'air séduisantes
comme ça ça non seulement voilà on a
peut-être oublié un peu vite que
généralement et bien c'est le médecin
traitant qui prescrit les médicaments
y at-il un risque peut-on parler
d'incitation au dopage
beaucoup en sont convaincus c'est le cas
du ministre de la santé qui a saisi la
justice dès ce matin claude evin est
avec nous en direct il répondra à nos
questions dans quelques instants dans le
journal
en attendant eh bien on va acheter un
petit coup d'oeil sur l'objet du litige
que voici
daniel bigot le dessinateur sempé a
raison les sportifs ne sont plus les
seuls à être concernées par le dopage
depuis aujourd'hui monsieur tout le
monde peut se procurer en effet le guide
pratique des stimulants musculaire
intellectuelle et sexuelle avec une deux
ou trois étoiles selon leur efficacité
écrit par des médecins se livrent
provoque la colère d'autres médecins
bien sûr ces médicaments la plupart de
ceux qui sont très actifs on les as sur
ordonnance mais chacun sait que les
ordonnances hélas on les a facilement
trop facilement des médicaments comme
les cortisone hic comme les amphétamines
x ont présenté comme relativement anodin
sans danger quand on les prend pas en
quelques temps alors qu'on sait
pertinemment pendant l'administration de
ces médicaments est pire encore à
l'arrêt de ces médicaments
les accidents prudhom peuvent survenir
après les coupe-faim par exemple il ya
des états dépressifs ya eu des cas de
suicide se sont jamais des médicaments
qu'on peut utiliser de façon anodine
malgré l'interdiction en france de peur
de la publicité pour les médicaments
vendus sur ordonnance
l'éditeur andré balland considère qu'il
ne fait que son métier dans ce livre
nous n'avons pas cessé d'indiquer qu'il
y avait des abus dangereux
interdit aux femmes d'enceinte interdire
aux enfants et greta ont pris un maximum
de précautions et je ne pense pas qu'on
puisse nous reprocher quoi que ce soit
je ne pense pas qu'ils aient derrère je
le souhaite je crois que ce livre est
indispensable si l'on veut bien
considérer que la france est adulte qui
m'a l'air parfois douteux une grande
surface a décidé ce soir de retirer les
ouvrages de la vente fait monsieur le
ministre
bonsoir vous avez décidé on l'a appris
en fin de matinée de saisir la justice
alors vous n'avez pas l'impression qu'on
en fait un peu trop de battage autour du
livre que voici
est ce que vous l'avez lu d'abord
monsieur le ministre je les jeux l'élu
mais quand j'ai pris connaissance en
effet de ce livre je dois vous dire que
j'ai été choquée j'ai été scandalisé
j'ai d'abord été choquée j'ai été
scandalisé en tant qu'homme n'est pas
acceptable que l'on propose une société
dans lequel il est nécessaire de se
doper pour réussir ce n'est pas une
société que j'accepte mais j'ai la
responsabilité en tant que ministre de
la santé de m'assurer de la santé
publique dans ce pays et ce livre est
dangereux
voilà pourquoi j'ai saisi la justice
mais monsieur milices petit point
crucial la plupart des médicaments qui
figure dans le livre là que vous avez
parcouru bas ils sont vendus sur
ordonnance moi j'ai l'impression que ce
livre il fait aussi de l'information non
les françaises et les français ont dans
leurs armoires à pharmacie des
médicaments qui sont en effet vendus aux
armes sur ordonnance mais que n'importe
quel jeune adolescent peut avoir accès à
la lecture de ce livre est donc ce n'est
pas simplement un problème de savoir si
ces médicaments sont en vente libre ne
sont pas en vente libre
c'est un vrai problème de santé publique
vous avez demandé qu'on saisisse ce
livre j'ai demandé au garde des sceaux
d'engager des poursuites pénales à
l'encontre de l'éditeur et à l'encontre
des auteurs dont d'ailleurs je dois
noter cela renforce au corps mon
irritation et mon appréciation d'une
situation scandaleuse c'est que ce sont
des acteurs qui se réclament d'être des
médecins et qui ont gardé l'anonymat
j'estime que ce n'est pas là une
position courageuse mais je voudrais
dire aussi que je ne pense pas que
l'ensemble du corps médical fois
incriminé bien au contraire je pense en
effet et le témoignage que nous venons
entendent en est la preuve que la
communauté médicale sera dénoncé cette
situation
vous semblez parlait en fait
d'incitation au dopage avec ce livre
mais est ce que il n'ya pas une
incitation très officielle celle-là de
pages sous la double pression de
l'industrie pharmaceutique ou ou même du
corps médical
les français sont quand même champion de
la consommation des somnifères et des
tranquillisants
vous avez d'abord noter qu'à propos de
cette affaire le syndicat de l'industrie
pharmaceutique s'est élevé contre cette
situation et je dois dire qu'il s'agit
là d'une preuve de maturité
nous avons des discussions avec
l'industrie pharmaceutique
et je pense que nous pourrons aboutir
effectivement à une maîtrise des
difficultés que peuvent connaître tel ou
tel l'indus tel ou tel secteur
industriel tel sur tel ou tel produit
aujourd'hui le problème de la
consommation du médicament est un grave
problème chez les jeunes nous assistons
j'ai reçu au cours de ces derniers jours
les spécialistes
plusieurs spécialistes français de la
drogue ils m'ont décrit que nous
assistons aujourd'hui à une modification
de la consommation de drogues chez les
jeunes notamment qui abandonnent des
drogues dures qui passe à des drogues
médicamenteuse alliée à des alcools par
exemple et qui fabrique des cocktails
incité c'est ça qui me révolte dans
cette situation inciter à la
consommation de médicaments et même la
valoriser car en fait il s'agit bien là
de valoriser la consommation de
médicaments est absolument inadmissible
prenant le médicament dans l'armoire à
pharmacie en fait mais si les
médicaments il existe ces médicaments
ils ont été prescrits ils ont été
prescrits à des fins thérapeutiques
précise i lya sur un certain nombre de
ces médicaments des contre indications
qui ne sont pas indiquées dans ce livre
chez balland disais tout à l'heure
j'espère qu'il n'y a pas d'erreur j'ai
relevé un certain nombre d'erreurs gérer
levé sur un médicament que je ne citerai
donc pas cette phrase c'est une bouée de
sauvetage pour tout créateur en proie à
l'angoissé d'un délais à tenir très
précisément sur ce médicament la
contre-indication médicale est justement
l'angoissent il y a donc non seulement
un danger global à propos de la sortie
de ce livre
mais ce livre est truffé d'erreurs et je
pense que au cours des prochains jours
les spécialistes qui se pencheront
d'ailleurs sur ce livre seront
démontrées monsieur le ministre je vous
remercie vous restez avec nous car nous
allons aborder une information qui
mérite une autre réflexion celle cette
fois ci du porte parole des goûts
en nommant on a appris aujourd'hui que
la banque de france relevé d'un quart de
point son taux d'intervention sur le
marché monétaire
apparemment les autorités françaises se
sont résignés à cette décision
que s'est il passé monsieur le ministre
celle francky et qui est en mauvaise
santé pour parler là aussi au cros
ministre de la santé
nous on sait absolument pas le franc qui
est en mauvaise santé lors d'une réunion
tout à fait régulière et hebdomadaire
que le ministre de l'économie et des
finances a eu hier avec le gouverneur de
la banque de france
ils ont en effet estimé qu'il était
nécessaire de s'adapter à la conjoncture
internationale depuis le mois de mai du
mois de mai jusqu'au mois d'août nous
avions réduit le taux d'intervention de
la banque de france qui nous avait
permis de nous ajuster de réduire ces
différentiels avec nos partenaires nos
partenaires ont eu une entame en l'air
république fédérale d'allemagne mais
l'occasion de monter un tout petit peu
eh bien nous continuons nous adapter à
cette situation il s'agit simplement
d'une adaptation
il n'y a pas d'autres interprétations
merci d'avoir répondu en direct à nos
questions la politique qui en bref on
appris aujourd'hui que les services du
premier ministre michel rocard
travaillait sur l'hypothèse d'un
référendum national sur la nouvelle
calédonie le 6 novembre les électeurs
seraient appelées ce jour là à se
prononcer sur le projet de loi qui fixe
le statut du territoire pour dix ans
dans la perspective des cantonales de
septembre prochain nous vous annoncions
hier soir que le maire rpr de grenoble
alain carignon soutiendrait haroun
tazieff l'ancien secrétaire d'état du
gouvernement fabius
la nouvelle suscite vous vous en doutez
quelques commentaires notamment celui de
lionel jospin qui participe en ce moment
à l'université d'été du parti socialiste
en savoie écoutez sa réaction c'est au
micro de jean-michel mercurol je ne
crois pas que le peuple français s'étant
exprimés nous ayons vocation nous
asservir de force d'appoint à d'autres
il
donc si monsieur k réunion veut soutenir
haroun tazieff c'est très bien si
monsieur haroun tazieff voulait soutenir
alain carignon ça serait pas mon accord
les télégrammes d'actualité avec claire
chazal ensuite nous reviendrons sur la
sphère des parcs m une information qui
fait beaucoup de bruit dans la capitale
sur les enfants de couples nique
georgina dufoix puis annoncé cet après
midi aux mères françaises que douze cars
avaient été réglés cet enfant devrait
prochainement rentrer définitivement en
france
les inondations qui ont frappé le soudan
ont touché environ un million de
personnes dans la seule région de
khartoum mais il faut maintenant lutter
contre le choléra ou la dysenterie un
enfant de moins de 5 ans sur quatre
serait atteint ils sont des centaines
déshydraté parfois mourant à s'entasser
dans les hôpitaux
le parrain du milieu marseillais
incarcéré à la prison des baumettes
francis vanverberghe dit francis le
belge extradé hier de belgique a été
inculpée ce matin d'infraction à la
législation sur les stupéfiants
le belge est tombé après les révélations
d'un truand repenti ayant témoigné dans
la sphère du juge michel jacques chirac
et jean pierre chevènement le ministre
de la défense côte à côte pour célébrer
l'anniversaire de la libération de paris
il y à 44 ans les troupes du général
leclerc entrait dans la capitale dans
leurs discours place de l'hôtel de ville
les deux hommes ont rendu hommage au
général de gaulle part il doit rester le
lieu du combat pour l'homme a notamment
déclaré jacques chirac à paris on
commence à y voir un peu plus clair dans
l'esprit au parcmètre plus de 25
employés de la ville de paris qui
détournait l'argent des parcmètres
depuis deux ans ont été interpellés et
pour l'instant 5 tonnes oui j'ai bien
dit 5 tonnes de pièces ont été saisies
la plupart du temps l'argent était
entreposé dans des pavillons de banlieue
et bien nous avons retrouvé la trace de
l'un de ces pavillons reportage anne
consigny commentaires de rémy roche
cet enseignement dans la région de meaux
à orly sur morin dans ce pavillon qu'une
bonne partie du trésor de guerre des
pilleur de parcmètres a été retrouvé son
propriétaire roger ranque est employé à
la collecte des horodateurs est sous les
verrous
inculpé d'abus de confiance tout comme
sa femme concierge d'une école à paris
qui l a été laissé en liberté et qu'ils
avaient un train de vie un peu trop beau
pour le la situation qu'ils avaient
savez ça nous regarde pas tellement bon
oui c'est sûr mais enfin on il a
toujours été très très nébuleux sur sa
sur sa situation c'est un garçon qui est
très très discret 1 nous a simplement
dit qu'ils étaient fonctionnaire à la
mairie de paris puis c'est tout bon
maintenant tous les gens à acheter une
voiture
camping car ici et ça vous savez à la
limite on skie wallon n'a pas été
comptés avec 1
en tout 25 employés de la mairie de
paris ont été interpellés au moins
treize d'entre eux sont ce soir inculpés
et 9 écroué
d'autres personnes devraient être
interrogés à leur retour de vacances le
trafic qui porterait sur 20 millions de
francs peut-être plus semble avoir été
organisée depuis de longs mois
mais à l'intérieur d'un cercle restreint
excluant la complicité de responsables
importants de la mairie de paris
voilà dernière précision vient
d'apprendre georges sarre qui est
secrétaire d'état aux transports demande
à la municipalité de la capitale en tant
que président du groupe socialiste au
conseil de paris de s'expliquer à propos
de l'escroquerie des parcmètres à
marseille confusion à la prison des
baumettes une fois encore ce sont les
conditions de détention qui se retrouve
sur la sellette ce matin
l'intersyndicale des gardiens de prison
à manifester pour dénoncer le laxisme de
la direction mais au même moment une
délégation de l'association des familles
de détenus apporté son soutien à la
direction et chercher à entamer le
dialogue
comment en est on arrivé là et bien
isabelle weschler et luc bachofen non
essayer de comprendre
voici le reportage et surveillants des
baumettes sont mécontents ils menacent
de faire une grève du zèle si
l'administration pénitentiaire
n'augmentent pas leurs effectifs
en clair cela signifierait privé
purement et simplement les détenus
d'activités telles que musique échec
vidéo ou musculation entre autres et que
ses activités
il faut signaler que nous sommes pour
nous sommes par contre contrairement à
ce que certains jours nous ont dit non
seulement il faut qu'elle soit structuré
il faut une mise en place il faut
qu'elle soit encadrée ce n'est pas le
cas l'association des familles de
détenus qui existe depuis les émeutes de
l'été dernier avait choisi de venir
rencontrer les surveillants à cette
occasion ce matin mais le dialogue a
tourné court
c'est pour faire aboutir vos
revendications on est tout à fait
d'accord pour demander est ce que vous
ayez davantage de personnel on est prêt
à écrire à la chancellerie pour vous et
il m'a été répondu qu' il n'avait pas
besoin de l'association pour faire
aboutir leurs revendications et qu'il
n'acceptait pas le dialogue avec nous
problème majeur des gardiens des veaux m
les modifications rapides et
l'enrichissement de leurs tâches
auxquelles ils ne sont bien souvent pas
préparé d'où leur inquiétude partir d'au
moins vous vous demandez aux gens de ne
plus être uniquement celui qui ouvre qui
ferme à partir du moment où leur
demander d'assumer une fonction d'un
assumer aussi une responsabilité
d'assumer parfois l'animation il est
certain que certains ont du mal se
trouver mais je crois que l'immense
majorité
contrairement à ce que les apparences
peuvent
laissé entendre à deraa à faire autre
chose qu'à être des gens qui ouvrent qui
ferme une porte tout le monde est
d'accord au fond pour apaiser le malaise
en prison que ce soit celui des détenus
ou celui des surveillants mais la bonne
volonté l'initiative sont souvent
contrecarrée par la pauvreté chronique
de l'administration pénitentiaire il
faudrait investir le sport et plus
particulièrement le cyclisme nous sommes
et où il champion du monde de tandem
frédéric magné et fabrice cola que voit
si on remportait tout à l'heure la
finale du championnat du monde c'était à
gand belgique
ils étaient opposés aux allemands de
l'ouest george grey et ouvrait boutemane
ils ont remporté facilement la première
femme la deuxième manche
colas qui est en tête et emma n'y
étaient les grands favoris il faut dire
qu'ils avaient déjà à décrocher le titre
l'an dernier et qu'ils avaient réalisé
ma foi le meilleur temps lors des
qualifications
c'est pas évident vous savez le tandem
on reparle du saint suaire de turin
depuis quelques mois des échantillons du
saint suaire sont analysés dans trois
laboratoires des laboratoires anglais
allemands et américains
si tout va bien on devrait enfin
connaître l'âge exact de la relique
c'est la toute première fois que
l'église accepte que l'on examine le
saint suaire patrick esther depuis 1578
des millions de pèlerins se sont
recueillis devant lui à la cathédrale de
turin une pièce de lin de 4 mètres de
long sur 1 mètre de large sur laquelle
se distingue clairement les traces d'un
corps humain les empreintes de blessures
et même les traces de pieds et de mains
transpercé par des clous pour les
fidèles ce tissu avait enveloppé le
corps du christ après sa descente de
croix
toutefois l'histoire de ce linceul
méconnu que depuis le 14e siècle et pour
beaucoup il s'agit d'un faux pas à cette
époque pour éliminer le doute
le vatican a décidé de confier des
échantillons prélevés sur le saint
suaire à trois laboratoires la américain
selon allemand le troisième britannique
ici à oxford
les scientifiques vont donc dater avec
précision les échantillons grâce à la
technique du carbone 14
leurs résultats seront dépouillés par le
british museum et le vatican
les trois laboratoires doivent
impérativement fournir la même natation
est là deux cas se présenteront
ou bien le tissu à 2000 ans et il est
contemporain de jésus-christ ou alors il
date du 14ème siècle et cette info les
résultats seront connus avant la fin de
l'année toutefois dans les deux cas un
mystère subsistera comment a été faite
cette empreinte qui représente un visage
en négatif au 14e siècle la notion de
négatif n'existait pas il a fallu
attendre la photographie au 19e siècle
pour la découvrir
pour cet autre savant américain kevin
moraine il n'y a pas de doute possible
avec ses ordinateurs il a enregistré
l'image du saint suaire puis l'analyser
selon lui ces traces ne sont pas pinte
elles ont été produites par des
radiations lumineuse d'intensité très
violent certains diront le flash de la
résurrection
le mystère est donc encore loin d'être
percé avant de rendre l'antenne voici
pour les torts fils je sais qu'ils sont
nombreux à suivre le journal de 20h sur
antenne 2 les rapports du tiercé du
quarter c'était cet après midi à
vincennes dans la 3e course le prix de
sa voix vous lisez comme moi le tiercé
12 6 9 voici les rapports pas très pas
très grave pas très bien payé le quarté
12 6 9 15 c'est un petit peu mieux un
peu plus de 4000 francs et 405 francs 50
dans un ordre différent
après le journal vous retrouverez
laurent cabrol pour la météo aux
alentours de 22h50 c'est la dernière
édition avec aubry et de l'air demain
n'oubliez pas vous rendez vous habituels
6h45 télématin 13h le journal de la
mi-journée présenté par hervé claude je
vous retrouve demain à 20 heures
merci de votre fidélité et bonsoir
or